well I sent out a survey about five
years ago I was first contemplating this
book I said I want to know what your
biggest challenge is and hundreds and
hundreds of responses came back and some
people responded multiple times with
different challenges it became very
clear very quickly that the biggest
challenge business owners and
entrepreneurs have is knowing where
their biggest challenge is so the
biggest challenge is simply knowing what
the biggest challenge is there's a lack
of clarity everyone was rushing to the
apparent so that became the thesis of
the book to resolve that Michael Michael
Ovitz in the building how are you doing
man I'm in the house I'm doing well mate
how are you yeah very good thank you
nice use of mate as well I like that
completely anglicized everything haven't
we
yeah it's it's good it's good man so
we're talking about business today we're
talking about how businesses can upgrade
and level themselves you know we've got
a period of entrepreneurial turmoil at
the moment - yeah big challenge um let's
forget the current situation that we're
in why can operating a business be so
difficult because you've got your
product or service yeah and there's
customers who need it so yeah why why
does chaos in shoe why is it not just
plain sailing yeah there's a million
moving pieces no no that's the exact
number but there's so many different
elements that we need to do so it's it's
a prioritization problem when when
everything comes at you equally I think
many people come to work with a vision
or plan for their work I do and yet you
open email and there's this incessant
unstoppable chain of questions and
direction and demand along with your
vendors and clients so it's it's about
being pulled in all these different
directions we don't prioritize we don't
know how to prioritize what we need to
do and and therefore we try to do
everything with equal urgency so I you
know most business owners it's just this
circuitous circle of not making progress
but there's also this relentless need to
do something anything you know you um
use it in your book about putting out
fires and that it's it's funny that you
say that because that's what me my
business partner constantly feel like
we're doing it's just like what you know
that
of whack-a-mole yeah oh that's exactly
what this is you you can never win right
but but the funny thing is in
whack-a-mole you get points every time
you and so in our business you know
every time we accomplish something we
give ourselves that conscious or
subconscious pat in the back and say
yeah another thing down superheros swept
in save the day yet again but then the
next mole presents itself and you're
whacking again so this is actually human
biology we put extraordinary
significance in recent emotion and wins
so completing something feels good but
we don't we're not go to considering the
long-term consequence so we get this
little dwarf and release completed a
task got that done but we're not
considering how that task will serve us
in the long term so it just becomes this
perpetual series of just wagging things
down I mean perfect example of this is
people that will be working from home at
the moment for the first ever time I've
had a lot of messages from people saying
mate I have no idea how you do this on a
daily basis they're used to working in
an office perhaps with more structure
with a boss who's some combination of
giving them a direction and breathing
down the neck yeah and they just ring
when they go to work and everyone that's
listening will know this feeling because
doesn't matter you can even be as
someone with a very prescriptive job
like an engineer and not just a
knowledge worker working in the chaotic
kind of mental space yeah um you go to
work you're busy all day you're adamant
that you've done things and then you
look back at the end of the day and you
say what I do today no I don't know I
know I was busy and I know that I did
some stuff yeah but upon reflection I
feel like maybe actually I didn't do
anything you know it's funny so when
when someone else is giving us direction
they are theoretically doing the
thinking for us so it does become very
task-oriented and we can at least say
the other day I did what I was told and
that that feels like accomplishment when
when we're the ones telling us what to
do that's when it becomes the real
problem and so these these people are
working a friend mine is called the
distributed workforce as opposed to work
from home it's the distributed workforce
there's this autonomy now you're at home
and you're the one has to tell you
what to do and therefore there's this
propensity to move to the apparent
issues it's such a trap there's
countless apparent issues the question
though is which one's the impactful one
and of all the things present in front
of us
mathematically only one thing can be the
most important at the time we need a
tool or a way to differentiate that
otherwise it becomes this you know Mouse
and the spinning wheel we keep on moving
but our making forward progress it's
very frustrating but it's human nature
that was a homily that I needed
reapplying to me when I read fix this
next your book and that that point that
can only be one highest priority they
can only be one most important thing by
definition right by definition and you
know these he's here he's company saying
here's our top 10 priorities for this
year it's like that's [ __ ] you can't
have 10 what's the number-one priority
well they're all important uh-huh and in
that that caused the trap and if we
bring this down to more of a micro level
on a daily basis or by an hourly basis
for an individual business owner or
employee everything is a priority same
thing like all those little micro tasks
are priorities and that this is not
mathematically possible but what it
allows us is to escape contemplation
what I believe between every action and
reaction there needs to be contemplation
what we default to though is incomes
that request action I'm going to react
and you know take an action around it
delete it or respond to it or to
complete the task
but contemplation is where we start
prioritizing the true nature
prioritizing what's important and needs
attention what's important and can be
deferred what's unimportant and should
be avoided and and then we can start you
know differentiating things out but we
don't give ourselves time for that
contemplation that's the problem I
suppose as well you can have too much
time for contemplation which is why that
paradox if chippies comes in right and
you end up yes just wallowing around in
you to-do list with you just sweat
drowning in papers and you're no idea
what's going on so let's get into what
is the problem
that the fix this next analysis is
solving yeah so fix it the core problem
I called the survival trap and how do
you can imagine this is if you take on a
piece of paper you write the letter A on
a large piece of paper right in the
center put a circle around it that's
representative of where we are right now
point a right it's it's the either
crisis or maybe there's opportunity but
it's whatever we are considering in the
moment and in many businesses
particularly right now it's crisis
oriented there's there's demand on us
well any action any direction we go away
from point A will give us relief so say
the crisis is we need more sales well if
I draw an arrow from point A up saying
and that represents hiring a Rainmaker
employee well I can also draw an arrow
to the right that says we're gonna cut
prices by half after an hour to the left
saying that we can offer a prepay coupon
you buy four products today and give us
money and you'll get it in the future or
whatever you can keep drawing these
arrows in any direction you go we'll get
you out of Point a giving you relief
that's but there's a problem here if the
business needs you going to point B and
you can draw this out on that piece of
paper in the bottom left corner of that
paper draw that they're being put a
circle around it that's where the
business needs to go you'll see that
many of the decisions we made in this
little example the arrows weren't
pointing in that direction in fact in
some cases the arrow goes in the polar
opposite direction taking us further
away from the business needs to go well
I call this the survival trap this this
urgent need to get out of crisis
but taking us yet to a new crisis so
what we need is a tool and this is what
I share fix this next a specific
strategy to nowhere point B is it's not
about doing the the right thing is doing
the right thing at the right time you
know sometimes we're doing the right
thing we're doing the wrong time it's
like my house is working other times
we're doing the wrong thing at the right
time and it doesn't work it's it's the
combination of two we need to do the
right thing in the right time so we need
clarity on where the hell we need to go
in the first place yeah can you tell us
that the biggest problem quote can you
give us that because I absolutely love
that
oh yeah right this is the thesis of the
book I'll tell you how it came about the
conception I I have a sizable readership
I'm very blessed to have an
contact well I sent out a survey about
five years ago when he was first
contemplating this book I said I want to
know your biggest challenge is and
hundreds and hundreds of responses came
back and some people responded multiple
times with different challenges it
became very clear very quickly that the
biggest challenge business owners and
entrepreneurs have is knowing that their
biggest challenge is so the biggest
challenge is simply knowing what the
biggest challenge is there's a lack of
clarity everyone was rushing to the
apparent so that became the thesis of
the book to resolve that everyone if you
can teach me in my business partner to
work out what our biggest problem is I
will be you will have done more than
we've done in thirteen thirteen years of
business because you're already well
that's my goal then we'll do it we got
40 minutes to go okay so let's talk
about the business hierarchy of needs I
recently had um Scott Barry Kaufman on
the guy that hosts the psychology
podcast big time lover of Abraham Maslow
so we've recently recently gone through
Maslow's hierarchy of needs
perfect but today we're talking business
hierarchy of needs what other yeah and
and they're they're very similar with
one extraordinarily important and
significant differentiation so back to
mass laws then you're very familiar with
the basis physiological all the way up
to self-actualization what Maslow was
arguing and what's important as it
translates over to the business Harkov
needs is that if a base level need is
not being satisfied that becomes a
primary need the example I use is the
base level is physiological breathing
air drinking water the next level above
that safety needs like seeking shelter
from the elements or clothing or
protection from harm well if I'm outside
I live outside New York City and some of
these winters we get here are you know
sub-zero I'm talking Fahrenheit whoo so
sub 30 minus 30 Celsius
you know freezing temperatures if I'm
outside in a t-shirt and these
temperatures coming in I will
biologically respond by seeking shelter
and clothing immediately cuz otherwise I
will die from hypothermia
conversely if while I'm out there all of
a sudden someone puts a plastic bag over
my head and wraps duct tape around my
neck I'm now suffocating my primary need
has shifted to even a more base level
need physiological I need air I will
tear at that bag to rip it open because
I'm dying for air though the freezing
doesn't matter until I get that bag open
then I'm running for shelter
so Maslow says if a base level needs not
being satisfied we revert to it or our
business has a similar structure but
there's one significant difference and
I'll explain the structure for business
the significant difference is this we
are not biologically wired into our
business you know we are biologically
wired into ourselves therefore if you're
walking down a dark alley in Newcastle
and you oh this doesn't get the creeps
that someone's gonna attack you all if
you should turn yep turn around and walk
away and the reason is is your senses
sight smell hearing are triggering that
emotion in our business we're not
neurologically wired yet business owners
consistently say Chris oh I trust my gut
I need more sales I can feel it I need
it you know you can't feel it it's
impossible to feel it because they're
not neurologically wired in its it may
be a beacon a call to action maybe
there's an instinct that's triggering
but we actually need the empirical data
here's here's the business Harkov needs
and you and your partner can start using
this in your business right now the base
level needs for all organizations are
sales that is the creation of oxygen for
a business we need inbound cash flow but
immediately above that is profit profit
is the creation of stability for an
organization now these two are already
interrelated and all the levels are the
foundation must be strong enough to
support the level above it but it just
needs to be adequate for example I need
sales and I ask myself in my business am
i creating sales any sales and if the
answer is yes I then ask simply the next
question am i creating enough sales to
support a degree of profitability are my
sales adequate and this is where
businesses already get messed up many
businesses owners don't consider this to
build the organization they simply say
sales cures everything we need to sell
our way out of it which is the biggest
bunch of lies ever sales do not cure
everything sales actually translates to
organizational stress stress the more
sailes I have the more responsibility
placed on my organization and if I'm a
small company and I and I run the
business that's more stress on me so
sales is important to the degree that it
supports profitability profitability is
stability and sadly right now with this
crisis going on with kovat and so I see
business after business here and where I
live
outside New York City collapsing because
all they cared about was sales they
don't have any runway of cash no
protection no stability and within weeks
some of them in days of the crisis are
out of business for life well I mean I
think that reflects business owners and
generally people's personal proclivities
with the way that they set their own
finances up right there's a tragic that
statistic that I think 80% of Americans
don't have more than one month of cash
set aside you know like that months gone
that mom's been asure on everyone's mind
we're done it's happily abysmal when you
vote you ratchet that up to the business
level yeah
and you're like that's we had five
working days of capital that's how much
liquidity we were playing with yeah it's
so what happens is desperation kicks in
now we started doing desperate moves to
save the business big sales big discount
anything to save the business which if
it stabs the immediate moment if it
saves you you're simply point a and you
drew an arrow out the crisis will be
worse because now how you're gonna
recover from this you're making less
less make you're making less profit
you've even even undermined the company
more so people focus on how much they
make not how much they take and those
are radically different level to in the
business hierarchy of needs how much
does your business taking that is the
stability organization but once we
achieve that we simply ask ourselves do
we have a degree of stability do we have
enough stability to support the next
level in the business Harkov needs which
is order order is the creation of
efficiency efficiency gives the business
strength because organizational
efficiency reduces the dependency on any
individual that if the business owner
gets sick and that used to be an analogy
now it's very real you can get sick and
are taking on the business for weeks or
months can the business continue to
deliver on its values and promises to
its clients
and this isn't truce for the boss it's
true for anyone in the organization can
in the and the business and there's
other opportunities and efficiency that
as a business delivers on efficiency it
can bring more value and more margin to
a business benefiting profit so these
all work interrelated that the reigning
two levels and the business hierarchy of
needs are impact impact is the creation
of transformation this is where your
business is beyond the transaction of
the service or products that provides
it's about transforming the lives of
people people it touches and then the
highest level of business is called
legacy which is the creation of
permanence this is when a business
achieves permanence what I found is
that's when the business owner realizes
they were never business owners they
were stewards of this organization it's
its own entity and it's meant to live on
without them beyond them so these are
the five levels and the final floor I
want to share about the business heart
give needs is this is not a ladder it's
not about climbing to the top and waving
to your friends from the top what it is
is a pattern of needs that need to be
addressed and we simply ask her
questions is the base adequate to
support the level above it is that level
adequate to support the level above that
and if not we have to revert to the base
lightly building a building a structure
of five storeys you don't start on the
fourth storey and say that's what's put
a building up here and it falls into
thin air and collapses and at the same
time you don't build this massive
basement foundation and put a little
toolshed on top of it because it would
fall in it they have to work
relationally what are some of the common
mistakes that you see business owners
making which go against the fix this
next analysis or the business hierarchy
of needs how do people get this as wrong
as they can get yeah well I'll give you
the two most common because it can write
to mind the first most common
particularly in startup businesses is
they focus at the impact or legacy level
they go into business saying we want to
change the world I will do everything to
be that you know the business that just
changes everything and then they don't
think or consider the foundation of
sales they don't master profit or
efficiency they just go or change in the
world and very quickly the business has
no structural
rigidity below it and the business
collapses on itself there's these great
ideas and concepts that just deflate
upon themselves so that's the most
common problem the second one is sales
cures all it is a horrible belief they
just build this foundation and
foundation of sales true story I have a
friend who a dear friend who had a
company up to 250 million dollars u.s.
and annual revenue and yeah exactly and
that's what people say whoa that's a big
business and sadly collapsed within two
weeks
not if the Cobra virus of a bad
strategic decision they made six months
ago and the entire business collapsed
like that because they made a bad
strategic decision they didn't consider
the next level of profit they didn't
bring stability financial stability to
the organization so it's a shame but
most many business owners think that
sales cures all and our egos tied to it
that's the kind of a third component
it's like it's all about the entrepot
Joneses you know I got to keep up with
you you're doing a million I gotta do
two million you're doing - I gotta do
five it's this constant back and forth
of the vanity metric of sales and
revenue without the consideration of
sanity of cash profits fun top-line is
[ __ ] top-line is [ __ ] has been
[ __ ] for as long as I've done
business so I'll tell you a little bit
about what I do I run nightclubs that's
been my job I'm a club promoter in the
UK we've fortunate we've got a lot of
cities Newcastle Manchester Leeds some
big party cities people like to go out
and they like to have good events to
head to and thankfully we can service
that need but in our industry it's very
easy it's like it's kind of like a
football match or like a sport game yeah
every week and you've got your match and
your competitors your rival teams have
all got their matches and they say we
did we did 2,000 people tonight well we
did 3,000 Peter you like well I know for
a fact that your venue capacity is only
1,800 like where did you fit the extra
1,200 people but there's so I see this
right I see this manifest and everybody
is that's listening will know the friend
that talks about maybe they don't give
out the pure
figures of how much money they took but
it's it was this busier we did a
restaurant owner that always talked
about how many covers they did last
night it's like you're not telling me
about how your business rates on that in
ridiculous location you've got are
completely pulling your ass out yeah and
you're having to pay yourself dividends
out of the company in a desperate
because your directors wage isn't
covering the car payments that you've
got to do or your mortgage or whatever
it might be
um and again as a final example that
kind of comes from my own experience
with regards to this sales versus profit
relationship typically price elasticity
of demand would suggest that when you
put the price up your level of demand
goes down so me my business partner you
can imagine we have these club nights
some of them are really cheap entry you
know a one-pound for a very early on
entry and then it maybe goes up to five
and six pounds later on and um we were
looking at we were like I just can't get
this night to become as profitable as we
wanted to we know it's popular we know
that it's good how come we're looking at
stripping back costs and doing this that
any other but you're always concerned
about putting your price up because you
know there's so many competitors that
can come in they can always jump in and
go and get it and I it's usually my
business partner that's the the guy
that's kind of on the grind for the
finances stuff but for once I was like
look man that's just let's see what
happens if we put the entry price up
across the board by a pound we did in
the numbers didn't move and you add
because of the way that there's no
there's no variable costs does zero
variable cost if you walk past the front
door or if you go in it's the same I
don't have to make you the food I have
to sell you the drink I literally take
the money from the door and it was like
that's 800 pounds a week on your bottom
line
bottom line and top line for nothing so
to loop back round top lines [ __ ]
bottom lines everything I agree yeah and
people use I call entrepreneurial
rounding right so it's like oh you know
you know ten people show it felt like 50
so I'll say fifty and people say this
with the revenue too you know I can't
tell how many company say they do a
million dollars in revenue and I'll be
shocked if they're doing 500,000 or you
know it's right is it rounded to the
nearest million
yeah your brand in there yeah and it's
funny but we put such significance in it
I'm trying to change the question here
and when people say how BIG's your
business and people may not be so bold
to ask your revenue but they'll say how
many employees do you have
they'll try to guess it I say hey before
this conversation let's talk about how
healthy our business says and that's
when people like our deer-in-headlights
and what do you mean how healthy what's
this talk about the only number that
matters let's talk about profit and it
becomes a uncomfortable conversation for
very uncomfortable but that's that's all
it really matters I don't believe a big
business is better
I believe the right size business that's
very profitable is better well both
myself and you will know some business
owners who have a couple of employees
and turnover that the top line is ok
what they're that bottom line is the
sort of figure that huge hundred persons
medium-sized enterprises would kill for
yes I salivate when I yeah there's
people that do that and I aspire to be I
was the other guy I was the guy who was
bragging hey did seven mill this year
and I had a lawn furniture in my house I
couldn't afford furniture I I want to be
and I'm behaving consistently with it
for quite a period of time now is I
actually very proud of our small
business we've twelve employees and and
most of our employees are part-time
employees and I am proud of that and we
are achieving profit margins that are
very comfortable and give us a lot of
protection and that's what I want to
grow and I know people that have
achieved that 'men times even healthier
than I have and that that's the
aspiration for a good business I really
believe that moment look at this this
age of what we're doing right now you
know you're writing i'm podcasting yeah
got some podcasters even medium-size
guys in the u.s. less so in the UK some
medium-sized guys in the US that I know
that are turning over a hundred grand a
year as a as a side hustle for doing the
podcast
yeah and of the hundred grand turnover
they're probably keeping like 90 grand
in their pocket
what are their costs oh my my camera
lens broke because I sat on it and I
need to pay for my I need to pay for my
podcast hosting and maybe maybe get a
new microphone or whatever you've
totally right you can run these hyper
lean businesses so yeah definitely if
there's any entrepreneurs that that are
listening in a thinking yeah I've kind
of been a bit focused on on sales and
now I'm being told by Michael that I
need to perhaps flip that look at and
look at my profit a little bit more
about how how do we move from sales to
profit I mean there's only really two
figures right there's how much are you
taking and how much he's spending
exactly exactly so profit is is driven
by the exactly I think cost control
margin margin is the spread between what
you sell something for and what you
collect for right so we can always
increase where we should seek ways to
increase margin and reduce cost the
interesting thing is cost can only be
reduced by so much or there's a certain
point you can't cut costs anymore
because either cutting the muscle of
your company mean you can't produce or
you've hit zero and you can't go below
zero margin can always increase so what
I do with a lot of businesses is if they
have some degree of sales they at the
base business hierarchy achieved we then
say well what are the necessary costs
for that sales and we can cut in many
businesses 10 even 15 or 20 percent like
like that unnecessary subscriptions and
so forth you can cut a certain amount of
fat out of the business but certain
points are cutting muscle and you got to
stop there then we look at the margin
and that's where the big opportunity is
and in your your example at the door one
pound versus two pounds like that's you
doubled your margin that is it's a
hundred percent growth
that's unbelievable and no one flinched
that's the big opportunity and and what
as way I went to the business heart gave
needs and fix this next is interviewing
companies I found that the biggest
resistance about increasing margin is
actually not from the clients themselves
it's from the business owner thinking
that they can't do it in the first place
come on you are you are striking at the
heart of entrepreneurs across the world
at the moment like especially if you're
a small business owner you feel either
fear that you have that level of anxiety
that you have when you think about
putting the price up
is a unbelievable I remember the fun
believe it the first time that we
started to issues a long time ago now
first time that we're gonna raise the
price on the door and I was adamant that
was like right no one's gonna come no
one's going it's got two rounds fifty
two three pounds fifty before eleven
o'clock like it's a Saturday looking
back now in light it should have been
six pounds it should yeah yeah you
should have been two times it should
mean three times that but at the time
you just terrified completely completely
terrified no one's gonna come everyone's
gonna think it [ __ ] it's never worth
anything you know and the fine thing is
they could that is the exact feeling we
go through all of the worst-case
scenarios we're gonna lose clients and
so forth here's the truth if those
people didn't come and when you're
charging three pounds fifty when you're
charging that and clients don't come
that means they don't value that venue
as much as you want them to if you're
gonna say you know what an extra pound
no way that's not for me those are cheap
clients do you really want those clients
in the first place and that's what we
got to consider if people are not gonna
buy something at a higher price point do
they really value what we're offering
and it also means that then the onus is
on us to share the value to show the
benefits of paying the additional money
and that's the the challenge that many
businesses have is actually just
enunciated what value they deliver often
they just increase price they're afraid
of increasing price because people will
leave but they don't even consider if I
do increase price I need to tell them
the value that they're really getting
that's inherently there in many cases
these need to make it public and and
then you know when you do it you're
often surprised oh my gosh no one no one
blinked and I I should have done this
years ago I'm a fool well in other
businesses that aren't as easy to
acquire customers like I say it's the
same cost there's no variable cost
there's essentially no extra work for us
to do a thousand people versus five
hundred people
DJ's going to be their door staff in us
and blah blah blah it's the same it's
essentially the same event but a lot of
other businesses aren't and the
interesting relationship I think you
touched on at the very beginning way you
said that um increasing sales actually
increases headaches
yeah a lot of the time and if you had
the choice to make the same profit at
half the sales that you're doing at the
moment oh that's heaven you know like
there's a stage where you get to where
you like well it's
she could have the entire business
running off the back of one client which
is why you're now no longer hedged
against risk if that one client decides
to go oh that's right but everybody
knows where that or you should know
where that kind of middle-ground lies
and it's like yeah if you can continue
to use price as an indicator of quality
continue to move your way up to higher
and higher quality clients who need to
mean business more and more especially
if you're looking at b2b I'm gonna guess
you know if you're if you're in that
sort of a business and you keep moving
up that better better client range
another perfect example of one of the
co-hosts to the show Johnny and Yusuf
they used to do online coaching PT's
doing diet plans this that any other 50
pounds hundred pounds for a week beach
body ready type thing yeah yeah they
realized that the low cart value stuff
although that was what they understood
it wasn't what was getting them fired up
they switched and they started coaching
coaches so that cart value is now from
80 pounds to a thousand pounds yeah and
they'll do the same number of sales
calls but then and the conversion will
be lower they're not gonna sell as many
a thousand as they were eighty but the
period that they work with they love
they're serious you don't have someone
who just happens to spend a thousand
pounds on a course it's like I'm put
enough money in for this to be serious
so there's two examples from people that
the audience will know personally from
listening to this show who have had this
very situation that you're talking about
right now happen in their businesses it
reminds me of a story of the University
of Mississippi and the power of this
business are give needs and how making
shifts like you're saying and just
changing the perspective that you can
generate the same amount of income with
lot less effort
this story has just shocked me so
University of Mississippi is in what we
call the Southeast Conference this is a
conference of universities and there's I
think 15 universities in their
university Mississippi also called Ole
Miss Ole Miss what had the lowest
applicant rate of all the SEC schools
back about 15 years ago so people are
applying everywhere but Ole Miss and
they realize this is a sales problem
right we were lacking enough
applications on enough prospects well
they do in a study and they realize that
students pick a university within
typically five minutes of visiting that
campus based upon how the campus looks
it's a very instinctual I like this
place looks beautiful I'm in or this
place looks like [ __ ] I'm out
well Ole Miss unfortunately had the
reputation of looking like [ __ ]
so that was a sales problem they weren't
attracting enough prospects sometimes in
this business hierarchy you can get two
birds with one stone
well they realize they need to beautify
the campus they talk to there's a guy
named Jeff McManus there he Oh was the
oversaw the landscaping Ole Miss and
found that the landscaping team couldn't
maintain this 1,000 acre property
adequately they could just keep up with
the mowing and that was it they couldn't
do the beautification projects
installing plants and flowers well Jeff
talks with his team and says why why are
we struggling to beautify the campus and
they said because we're so inefficient
so the team talked about challenge at
the order or efficiency level he said
well what's the problem these guys said
we have these sit on mowers that we go
running down on the campus mowing the
lawns but the tree limbs are so low that
we get the jiggle back and forth around
the tree limbs to mow when we get to a
mulch patch where we have all the mulch
they are square patterns and we have to
do these angular cuts and slows us down
so they made some suggestions they said
let's just cut the tree limbs up about
two or three meters so that we can go
right under the tree limbs in a straight
line let's make the mulch patterns
oval-shaped so we can do sweeping
motions and keep going on they made
other changes too but was all about the
efficiency of these mowers they were
able to mow the entire 1,000 acre
property now in half the time which
meant the other half their time they had
available to do beautification projects
within a year of these changes the
efficiency at Ole Miss had improved so
much the beautification projects were
were implemented application rates
started to skyrocket back in early 2000
because now the students were coming to
campus and saying this is beautiful
Ole Miss today holds the prestigious
title of having one of those beautiful
campuses in all the United States
because they identified the hierarchal
needs they said we have a sales issue
the sales issue was triggered by another
opportunity
efficiency they combined the two killed
two birds with one stone in Ole Miss you
know benefited in a significant way I
love that so let's move let's move from
profit to order how we how we moving
from profit to order yeah so the
question is do we have enough stability
an organization to bring about
organizational efficiency some
businesses try to get more and more
efficient how do we get more done with
less effort without considering the
demand it puts on resources to do that
as you bring more efficiency to a
business it takes more effort to achieve
it woman 1 example 2 is in scalability
that the bigger you get efficiency works
to your advantage
there was a manufacturer I interviewed
in Pennsylvania they make place that's
they were the at the time before they
sold their company they were the biggest
place that manufacturer they're now a
part of a conglomerate and they had this
massive massive machine and this machine
would paint the playsets what was
interesting was the setup for a machine
to get ready to start running a run
could take about three to four hours of
effort maybe even more time so when when
you spend three or four hours doing it
one place that goes through and gets
painted in five seconds
it didn't get paint in five seconds it
got painted in four hours and five
seconds
well when the second one went through it
didn't get clean in five seconds it got
painted in two hours in five seconds
right because that set-up time has been
split in half as more would go through
it the set-up time became less and less
important so once you really get the
steam rolling and they were sending
thousands a set of places through they
are making money big time well that's
why efficiency is so important at this
level we first need to have some kind of
sales consistent sales in their
profitability sustainability and that
must be at a level of significant enough
that we start focusing on efficiencies
because it brings value back to the
organization that's how it works and as
you get more efficient it may trigger
you to say now we can support more sales
well let's go back to the sales level so
instead of climbing a ladder here we
start cycling back down we build the
base of sales stronger allows more
profitability allows more efficiency we
cycle back down and we'll start ping
pong around as the business grows kind
of like a like a volcano a mountain is
formed by a volcano flowing down more
lava and yet again and again and the
mountain gets bigger yeah I get it
the
so order your middle section of the
other of the pyramid I think this is
where me and my business partners spend
a lot of our time we're very
process-oriented we like to have there's
a document written for everything
anything that's ever happened that we
think might happen again there's a
process written for it and I think you
touched on that about the the owner or
the CEO the end the other partner or
whatever being ill or being unavailable
for a period of time and the business
being able to continue without them yeah
yeah I call it the four week vacation
and sometimes for a vacation czar not
planned we're all on one at the moment
yeah it's a corona vacation isn't it
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're yeah Tuesday
we're all on that but it was funny I you
know I speak a lot in the u.s.
occasionally in Europe and in the US no
one takes vacation you know you're
actually considered a week if you don't
work through vacations that you do take
and to horrible mentality because the
problem is a business becomes it's being
carried on the back by the business
owner and if they are taking I have a
corona virus or something the entire
business stops because the business
owner has failed and that it can go
under so the for vacation the idea is if
someone can leave a business for four
consecutive weeks and the business
continues to flourish with them fully
disconnected physically and digitally
there's a business that's no longer
depend on the owner it can grow on its
own well when I I toured through Europe
I was in Germany recently like you got
to take this four week vacation you know
people after me they said welcome to
August Europe shuts down yeah and it's
like oh my god this is predominately an
American phenomena but sadly it's it's
seeking it's kind of seeping out all
over the world that we need to be
workaholics and that's wrong we actually
need to prove that we can remove
ourselves in the business because it
will happen maybe it's not a vacation
maybe it's an illness or you get hurt
but it will happen and we need to remove
that dependency of of being on an owner
anyone that's listening who runs a
business or even it's just in a business
way you get to know who the CEO is just
take a second and think what would
happen if the boss left for four weeks
now and especially if you're a business
owner that visceral that fear that
you've got that rising in your chest
that makes you want to throw up on the
app
that's that is that's how I we felt for
a very very long time and especially in
this world now where increasingly you've
got lots of small businesses you know I
wouldn't like to guess what the average
number of employees is in a business in
the UK but I'd guess maybe something
like 20 probably you know like your 20
or 50 something like that like a typical
typical size company and that means that
the owners moved up through the ranks
they know the office they the landlord
owns the thingy they go out for beers
with the guy that owns the office block
that you know everything every little
bit and you've got your claws into all
of these different sects yeah and every
one of those claws needs unpicking one
buy all the way along to allow you to
relinquish that control it's a very
emotionally for something that's
supposed to be sales profit order
efficiency it's actually you getting to
the point now where you're like it's an
emotional interaction you need to let go
of and I loved your example because it
is talons in the business and the
removal is not like you just release it
sadly actually though that is the
perception of any business owner it's
that one day there'll be a switch
flipped somehow magically that also in
the business runs itself you're like I'm
retiring I'm selling this and I'm gonna
make tons of money but the reality is
this is a throttle we have to slowly and
specifically and deliberately extract
those claws one step at time from the
business and it can take sometimes
months
many businesses years to extract the
owner fully I've implemented in my own
business and I've now reinserted myself
and what I mean by this is I was running
the operations I was involved in every
little task well I started to remove
myself I've now brought on a president
that runs the company her name's Kelsey
she runs the organization and now the
business can run on the day-to-day
completely without me it's freed me up
to do what gives me the most a shin
which is be the spokesperson I love
talking shop like what we're doing that
now Chris I love this and I love writing
books so now I can do the things I'm
passionate about but if I get sick or I
leave the business yes the spokesperson
roles not filled but the core essence
the business will continue on here's a
perfect way for people to frame this as
well
if you're a business owner that's
listening and you've never relinquished
that control but as you've just
explained that Michael you were able to
bring someone on who is able to do the
things that you were capable of doing
think about that as a business owner if
you were able to bring someone on and
write them a document that was how to be
Michael dot doc X I can just write them
a big thing this is what this is how you
do me
so you know if someone can do the job
that you are doing now off the back of a
document that explains how to do it
where is your unique talent being placed
within this business you're just oh you
just a guy you're just a bleep bleep
bleep input/output like that's it that's
it there's no longer your unique
creative vision that's being deployed to
the business you're just computer
program yes right yeah we're avoiding
playing into our Strang's
and the funny thing is Kelsey doesn't
replace me Kelsey's like 10 times better
than me she understands uh you know her
super strength is in human connection
she my colleagues here have an adoration
for her that supersedes the adoration or
that they had for me and it's almost
painful to say that but it's realistic
and I love I love my colleagues I will
do anything for them and I feel the same
way about me but Kelsey Kelsey has that
something special they will take a
bullet for her they will protect and
defend her because she protects and
defends them so not only did she replace
me
she's amplified the strength of our
organization it's funny as I was writing
fix this next I was looking at
organizational charts and most org
charts are pyramid structures up top it
says don't even say president says the
word me Allah on arrow a long long line
going down to the minions down below
that's the vice president sales only
different things well those structures
are a structure that plays into titles
not into strengths a better
organizational structure is is as
matching someone's tasks or talents to
the task they have at hand a web-like
structure we actually don't have to no
one has titles here I acted a
spokesperson I write books but I don't
have a title
Kelsey actually the only want the title
she's the president because we need
that for certain discussion of something
and never needs to know that you know if
you have a small business but no one
else has a title they just serve roles
and what that's allowed is us to be very
dynamic in our capacity when we have a
massive order for say books that were
shipping usually our de server does it
but if we have to do it with three
people that can shift over to that no
problem if we have a large amount of
customer service calls we have one
person that caters that but with two
other people cross trained in that we
can shift resources there so by doing
role specialization and matching to
people's talents and removing titles it
allows this almost organic shifting of
the business and people don't feel
compelled to stick within their role of
the title yeah I love it so we've got
two left impact and legacy let's talk
briefly about impact yeah so it's a
fascinating transition that happens at
this level the first three levels we
talk about is about getting we need to
get sales get profit get efficiency in
our organization impact we flip the my
lands about contribution now of giving
impact is where we are serving our
client beyond the transaction it's
life-changing for them and now I say
life-changing I don't mean like you've
saved someone's life but there's a shift
in their life there's some kind of
meaning beyond the commodity and they
put significance in you the example I
like to use is Harley Davidson anyone
can sell a motorcycle buy a Harley
Davidson you now belong to the Harley
Davidson community or a weekend warrior
a tough guy or whatever the title is but
you belong to a family now you don't
have to transform people by making them
belong to a community there's countless
ways to do it but we want our clients
saying wow this is something greater in
my life than I ever expected and they
see that value that's transformation and
I will tell you this you don't have to
do it I don't think Walmart transforms
people's lives at least not here in the
US they actually probably deplete
people's lives quite frankly but but
they do deliver on the three levels very
well they're there they offer sales they
offer a value of cheapness they they're
profitable and they're efficient but I
don't ever transferring lives some
businesses can make this election and
this is when you start realizing to the
degree you are a steward of something
good here you you have a platform now of
service but it's a choice to be there
and I don't think it's better or worse
is this a choice
the highest level is impact impact is
the creation of permanence and this is
where you like it set your Mo's that
legacy no impact legacy I'm sorry legacy
legacy is the creation of permanence and
legacy is where you set your business to
live into perpetuity it's where you will
realize even you the founder are
important in this I mean you were
significant you served a role but it's
the business that's important and I can
continue to have its impact as a legacy
into perpetuity this was a question
you've already touched on it the I asked
should every business aim toward impact
and/or legacy you know it's I mean it's
gonna be challenging for me as someone
who gets 18 to 21 year olds drunk for a
couple of years while at university to
have a legacy you know I appreciate that
I understand what it is so how how do I
know I don't know whether I should let
go and also you've said as well some
people kind of set the sights on the
peak of the mountain and everything else
Falls yeah yeah so the answer is no not
everyone should do it we should speak to
what our heart calls out to do I have a
friend who's got a business that does 15
million us it is efficient it doesn't
need him he's making money and he's like
I'm off to the golf courses
he's think I'm gonna go golfing every
day yeah and and I'm like that is good
and I actually would argue use more than
good as noble because the company is
providing for employees it is giving
great services it's it's supporting the
economy but I also feel one day he'll
wake up and say is this all there is and
I think that's the calling when there's
that sensations is all there is we
realized that our business or a new
business can be a platform for
expression I've had for me that
transition I had businesses that made
money and I became a millionaire and I
thought it was all about the cars in the
big house and the vacation house in
Hawaii I thought that's what it was and
then I had the awakening for me I said
no no there's something else going on
and that's when I decided to devote
myself to having impact in legacy
additionally I'm absolutely responsible
to master sales profit in order you
can't skip levels here you can't just go
out and say gonna change the world
that's a business I'll collapse on
itself so I'm very regimented
in driving sales that are adequate to
support profit profit that can bring
about efficiency in order for me to have
impact and legacy well I love it before
we go I know that we're tight on time I
got one final thing upon you speaking
about the fact that you
manifested some of this material wealth
then got read pilled either by
combination of yourself and the way that
you in place that you were in your life
and then we realized that wasn't it um I
was listening to Navarre rava count on
Tim Ferriss and he gave this quote and
Manny it just hit me straight between
the eyes and he said it is far easier to
fulfill your material desires than it is
to renounce them Jay very true I wonder
whether or not part of your
transcendence this fulfilling of
potential and that the change of dynamic
has been serviced by the fact that that
box has been ticked that Michael no
longer has anything to prove on the year
I've had their home in Hawaii I've had
the date yeah
I think I think a lot of people might
need to go through that fire and
actually tick those boxes that make
sense it totally makes sense like it's
funny so we all know or heard that it's
not about the money it's not about the
acquisition of stuff but I also agree
that the only way for most of us to
discover that is to go through the
experience it's all willing good someone
telling us that but look at the people
who say it I know as they fly in their
private jet over you say [ __ ] you Warren
Buffett like stop telling me about how
then you can be and how easy and simple
life is because you no longer have to
play that game you've already done it so
man I've absolutely loved today fix this
next your book will be linked in the
show notes below are people want to
hustle you online where should they go
go to Mike motorbike comm it's actually
Mike McCalla wits but no one can spell
McHale oh it's Mike motorbike has in the
motorcycle is my nickname from high
school yeah so now forward to my site my
books are there free chapters I use
right for The Wall Street Journal you
can get that and I have my own podcast
there - what's the podcast called it's
called entrepreneurship elevated I love
it that'll be linked as well you know
what to do if you've enjoyed this
episode like share and subscribe all of
the stuff that we've gone through today
will be linked below man I think I
really love the framework I think it's
it's great and it's nice to read
look I did five years at Newcastle uni
Business School and I constantly read
things which didn't reflect my
experience in as a young business owner
and this is the precise opposite I'm
coming up with stories that tell you the
concept from your book because I'm
similar happened so man awesome thank
you so much for your time my brother
thank you
[Music]
you